we're certainly in a world of trial and
error right now I mean if you look at
the three fundamental key aspects that
economists focus on capital labour and
productivity there's a lot to be
optimistic about all those countries
we've got the got a lot of money they're
sitting on on vast populations in the
good labor dynamics and productivity
wise they're importing a lot of
technological advancements but the fact
of the matter is we don't really know I
mean I think if you look at what China
is doing I think that they will in the
foreseeable future I think continue to
pursue very aggressive policies which
will deliver so of all of these what are
the top picks well I think there's
another category which we do know is
probably on the right track and it's
when we introduce political economy that
we find it we see a lot of countries
where there's usually been a
center-right government that's come in
and introduced sort of Good Housekeeping
Seal of Approval economic policies and
then there's a center-left government
that follows them and legitimizes those
policies by spreading out some of the
gains from the economic growth that has
resulted we saw this in brazil with lula
but even before that we saw it in Chile
with Bachelet now we're seeing it at
uruguay with Mujica we might be seeing
it in Peru and Colombia soon and this is
a class of countries which is preparing
for stable long-term growth all of the
countries you just named are in Latin
America and they embody this new left
consensus but in fact it derives to some
extent from the gains that were made by
the center-right governments that you're
talking about right it's not that
pendulum that was swinging between the
populace left-wing governments and the
authoritarian right-wing governments
that pendulum has stilled in the center
but most people when they talk about
emerging markets are really talking
about Asia they are and I think there
can be a curse of being brick which is
that it tempts countries to sometimes
think the work is done and a lot of what
happened and I saw this in India and i
think it probably happened elsewhere
also when you get called brick by
goldman a certain class of the country
it kind of feels were all set and a lot
of that hard slog of development as
opposed to the sexy stuff of building
software companies and great university
campuses the hard slog of getting the
little things right over a 50-year
journey actually fall away from the
conversation so I think actually
sometimes it's not very helpful to keep
anointing people with these with these
acronym even when a country finds a rose
and it's locker it still has to prove
fundamental so very interesting insights
on which
urging markets are going to emerge more
on that and other relevant topics at big
thing calm